first of all always a pleasure to sit
down with you see you Steve um I your
resume I have a bunch of things I want
to talk to you about your resume is what
I call incredible when people want to
talk about the certain movies in the 90s
do more people want to talk about the
rock on air or Armageddon uh I think all
of the above they really do the rock is
a favorite a lot of people Armageddon is
fantastic and they talk about Pearl
Harbor they I mean a lot of my Myka Bay
films that I've been lucky enough to
work with him on her topics of
conversations no matter where I go well
the thing about those is that was a run
of like every year one of these it was
just it was just a crazy run and I mean
some of these are criterion movies now -
did you ever think - when you were
making Armageddon it was gonna be a
criterion movie never never you know it
was just fun entertainment and got
really lucky to get Bruce and Michael
together and they they hit it off they
made a terrific film I agree with that
statement jumping into why I get to talk
to you today this has been a project
that's been in I called whatever one
says development hell for forever
at what point and how many years ago did
you realize we are now on the precipice
of what the technology can finally do
well I think it over the last three four
years you finally could see when you saw
some of the de-aging that they were
doing that it's possible but egg doesn't
want to do the agent he wanted to create
a whole digital human being which he did
based on will and yeah yeah I was always
skeptical egg wasn't even sure himself
he could pull it off but he's very
confident man until we did a test before
we started to feel me did a test we took
a scene from bad boys in the car where
the two guys are talking to each other
so you have Martin talking to will and
what they did one of the shots of will
while they're talking they put a digital
will in there and the rest of the scene
is a real will I could not find the
digital will and I said I knew we had it
they showed that test today this is
morning before I did this job
and it was after they said one of those
shots was a digital will and I said what
the hell are you talking about I used a
different word but I'm trying to be PG
in this one right but I couldn't believe
it did you ever figure out which one it
was eventually when they showed it
didn't know myself they pointed out to
me
it's crazy yeah um one of the things I I
saw the high frame rate with the Hobbit
and I saw the high frame went with Billy
Lynn but I thought that the 3d high
frame rate in this was by a mile better
just it looked fantastic what what was
is there like a hurdle that all of a
sudden was overcome or just my eyes have
gotten used to it no it's it's it sang
it's it's learning from Billy Lynn and
watching The Hobbit and seeing how he
could make everything better and he
figured it out he knew you couldn't very
wear any makeup
he knew all these every little thing
shows you have to be so careful what
people are wearing what's in the
background every little dot on
somebody's face will show up so it takes
a long time to make sure everything's
perfect before we start filming one of
the things I thought with what with The
Hobbit was that you could tell that
people were on a sound stage when in
this movie where that when they're in
color get its Columbia or Carnahan you
yeah when uh but when they're on certain
locations I feel like I'm in a
documentary it's amazing isn't it it's
truly incredible how have you looked at
this technology and said what it might
be good for with other movies or certain
genres or you started looking at that
kind of stuff absolutely it just it what
has to happen is it is that cameras have
to come down in size they're so big the
3d K we had special rigs made it was
very difficult we had to have bungee
cords to help the the handheld work
because the cameras are so big and bulky
you know and heavy but you know what
when we started at the back of the
camera there were 20 wires going into it
by the time we finished there were six
that's crazy so as we were do as we were
making the movie the technology kept
advancing and will keep advancing so
well hopefully other filmmakers or
embrace this technology and start making
movies this way how what is the smallest
camera you could use on this that was
effective I
I would say well it depends if it was
the 3d rig it was about this big okay so
that's not terrible but normally it was
this big right no I'm just trying to
think because I think that you know
documentaries using this 3d high frame
rate I mean that's the future no no
kitty it's and I'm just wondering well
that would be easier because that
usually the the
the individual stationary so it'd be
much different unless your documentary
or following somebody around but it
still can be done it's going to be it
will happen I'm always curious about the
editing room because that's the final
rewrite what did you learn when you got
in the editing room maybe that you
weren't expecting and what made you like
excited well I think anytime you used
digital a digital world anytime the
visual effects start coming in because
usually you're working with a stuntman
or a double or something else when they
started putting in the real will and the
digital will it was spectacular so
before we were just watching the movie
with will playing junior where they had
edrick on until they replaced it so what
as it started evolving and you start
getting more shots of junior that was
great did you end up having a way longer
first cut and like a lot of deleted
scenes or was it pretty close they're
always a long first cut no matter what
movie you work on it's always long and
slowly as you pare it down and audience
tells you what they like and what they
don't like we get to it to the length it
is now what did you end up I know every
movie nowadays every movie does test
screenings and friends and family
screenings what did you learn from those
early screenings that impacted the
finish development we embellish the
ending we change the ending of the movie
so that is different because the
audience wanted more of more of the two
of them together and so we accommodate
them and it's a much different any I am
very curious off-camera I need to now
know what the article Toby yeah I was
gonna say what the other I'm trying to
think right now about that before I run
out of time the other day I actually sat
down with Eddie Murphy and he told me
that after coming to America to he's
doing Beverly Hills Cop for god bless
him
Russia he's always wanted to do it it's
just we could never get anybody else to
do it with him I'm not talking about the
studio's they were you know it's old
material what do we want to do it until
Eddie did dolomite and people said wow
he's fantastic because people haven't
seen him he's been semi-retired this
whole time you know raising kids and
doing that kind of thing mean being a
dad so when he cut me when he came back
and they start seeing what he was doing
everybody
real excited about making because I've
been pleading with everybody to make him
feel another W Scott for years a one of
the listen Eddie famously says he likes
sitting on the couch right and he told
me that he's viewing this chapter of his
life as like a bookend
we wanted to make a few comedies than if
he wants to sit on the couch he's fine
what he said to me he's gonna do it
after coming to America - do you have a
script and a filmmaker we have a script
which which we're redoing and no
filmmaker yet do you know when you might
be in pre-production on it or is it one
of these things that's a fast-moving
train I couldn't tell you when we're in
pre-production on it because it we got
to get the script right soon as we get
that right then we'll we'll be in
production sure um you have produced an
awful lot of TV right uh what do you
what's the next are you looking what's
the next thing that you're looking at
because the abundance right now of
channels and content that's out there is
is immense I'm just curious what you're
looking at for as your company for the
future well we're most of ourselves with
network television we have a show called
Lucifer which is now on Netflix so we're
kind of moving a little bit into
streaming we're still going to do still
do network because we love network
television and we're going to do
something for kwibi so we're good we're
expanding it in all the forms of digital
and entertainment